[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream we're going to start
slightly differently there are lots of
new people finding the podcast who may
not be aware of the trajectory that
we've been through so i am dr brett
weinstein and you as i understand it are
dr heather hying yes as if we're just
meeting each other for the first time as
if we are as if you as as you understand
it i have to say it makes me a little
nervous
and this is our this is our
120 seconds
live stream which we started a little
over two years ago
in uh in march of 2020 as kovid was
descending in the prior world mm-hmm um
the prior world that followed
was descending and then it quickly
became
ascendant and uh although many in the
world uh would seem to think that it's
disappeared now but it seems rather
ascendant in terms of its the markets
made what were you saying uh ascendant
but never once resplendent right i've
come to load this virus and really
resent the fact that some yahoos were
foolhardy enough to go around mucking
about
uh with the um the ancestors of such a
thing to see if they couldn't make it
infectious enough so that they could
learn how to fight an infection with a
virus like this
indeed
well today among other things we have a
sweet labrador snoring in the background
so if you're hearing noise that's what
it is
we're going to talk a little bit about
coming of age
in samoa in new jersey among the amish
and in the era of coven
and
also a little bit about how progressives
have sold out their
hour i guess depending on how we
continue to view ourselves values in the
last two years
uh putting at risk uh so many of the
gains that the liberals in general have
made over the last
you know 500 years
um i'm going to defend us preemptively
here just so that
if people go digging and they find this
they they they have some sense
um progressives are in favor of progress
but what you regard as progress could be
anything and so um you know it's it's
fine to be a progressive with a
completely independent view of all other
so-called progressives
and um i suspect that is where in the uh
the solution to that little puzzle lies
indeed
uh we're also going to talk a little bit
about vaccine mandates and uh you're
going to invoke the possibility of a gen
x revolution
indeed at the very end
okay so um we are uh
coming to you at our normal time on our
normal day in the upcoming months
there's going to be some changes to the
schedule but we will be here again next
week same time same place
and that is to say we're on youtube and
we're also on odyssey where the chat is
live if you are interested in that
we after our first hour hour and a half
or so we take a break and then we come
back with a live q a you can ask
questions for the live q a at
www.darkhorseadmissions.com that is open
now
we
we rarely get to all the questions but
we get to as many as we can and we pick
and choose so we don't promise that
we're going to get to any particular
question but we get to a lot of them we
get to a majority of them for sure
please consider
supporting us by subscribing to this
channel by subscribing to the clips
channel uh the dark horse podcast clips
where we have where our
excellent
other producer
makes clips of these streams and they
are they're
smaller more succinct bits that are
perhaps more easily shared
uh and that does seem to be the case of
how a lot of people are finding us
through through the clips i would add
check your subscriptions too because
there's something odd that's going on
with our our numbers on
youtube um we are encountering more and
more people who seem to be very familiar
with their work but that's not reflected
in the numbers and of course people
being unsubscribed without their
knowledge is a commonly observed feature
of the youtube universe indeed
uh you
we encourage you to join us on our
patreons where we do on on my monthly
private q a on brett's a couple of
monthly uh conversations and you also
get access to the discord community
there which is
um as we understand it very lively and
uh in the next few months we're going to
be uh announcing sort of improvements in
that space that should make it even more
even more exciting
um we have of course a hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century out now for
gosh almost seven months which is crazy
you know it was it was decades in coming
and it's out for almost seven months now
and continuing uh continuing to do
really well we continue to both um see
great sales but also more importantly um
have uh engagement over the content um
uh with this book so uh we we are proud
of it and we hope that you have the
chance to dig in
we have uh
direwolves and epic tabbies and digital
book burnings on our store at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
and um
my substance natural selections this
last week i
have forgotten what i wrote about this
last week i've been thinking so much
about what i'm writing about for the
next week which is partly why we're
going to be talking um about coming of
age was was there any uh thought crime
does that ring any bells
probably goodness i that's just what a
what a strange little glitch there um i
can figure this out quickly enough oh of
course
what i did this last week was i posted i
posted an essay that i actually wrote 10
years ago
from my time at navapatia which is an
extraordinary very small field station
on the sea of cortez on not not in baja
but on the mainland of mexico right near
the sonora sinaloa border um called
naturalist and sonora a place that i
went to
um
as part of my role as a professor
at evergreen um next week which also
seems a very long time ago it really
does
it really really does
um
but i did i was able to actually and
this is you know we'll get into our our
ads here um shortly but um
in service of where we're gonna start
today
i took a a peripatetic walk if you will
uh through a number of ideas and
and thoughts and readings and more ideas
and thoughts
and it reminded me of one of my favorite
concepts one of my favorite ideas in the
world which is serendipity
and you know being able to walk in a new
place where you don't have a goal you
have to be to or at least not at a
particular time or being in an actual
library where you can meander through
the stacks and discover um you know find
yourself in a section you never would
have gone to because maybe you didn't
even know that kind of thing existed but
now you find yourself among um the
thoughts of previous you know the
previously down thoughts of people uh
who may well have something uh to share
with you that will expand your world and
so that's
that's the sort of
expansive investigation i was doing a
little bit this week in part
complimented by and facilitated by the
fact that we had one
crazily beautiful unseasonably
just summer-like day it was it was
misfiled it was misfiled we're here in
the pacific northwest in portland oregon
and uh in in portland we have relatively
mild winters and perfect summers you
know the summers
last year we had a couple of crazy heat
waves like 115 degrees but in general
uh an august day is in is high in the
80s with very low humidity and it dips
down into high 50s at night so it's cool
enough to sleep easily it's a perfect
perfect temperature in the day and in
july
uh and in september it's in the 70s so
you know it really is perfect here and
that was what uh thursday here this week
was it was 75 degrees
you know blue sky some high puffy clouds
i actually got into the water i got out
paddle boarding for the first time this
year you got on your bike for the first
time in a little while it was glorious
and these sorts of
experiences of being out uh
without feeling you know cowed by the
weather without feeling like oh it's you
know it's it's dangerous out here it's
fraught um really can open up the brain
to to more
more being more open to ideas than you
might otherwise be serendipity
plan for it
yeah
okay
i don't know i thought i'd try it out i
actually i'm not convinced it's wrong
okay but you know so you say it yeah and
um
it's a thing yeah but then i'm supposed
to like riff on your pun
no that's not incumbent on you at all
right but when i just kind of move on
then then you and you know some of our
audience is like wow no but wow she
didn't like it if i recall correctly
we could uh
do the the slow-mo and see but i think
you chuckled so that's that's par for
the course
yeah
punsters man
okay
so we have um
we have three sponsors um that are um
very much helping support us this week
and we will bring them to you now
[Music]
our first uh sponsor this week is seoul
s-o-l-e a sustainable orthopedic
footwear company seoul is one of two
footwear sponsors that we have and we
love them both they are quite different
from one another yet both have an
evolutionary approach to creating shoes
that help feet get and stay healthy and
people become more mobile so i'll
intentionally bring structure back with
both their shoes and their footbeds soul
aims with its footwear to return our
feet to health and the shoes by soul are
beautiful i actually wore uh wore my
pair of soles last night and i was
reminded of how
how comfortable unusual but comfortable
and beautiful they are
soul has created a footbed that is
affordable customizable and improves
people's everyday foot comfort
furthermore they've created their own
recycling program re-cork to collect and
upcycle wine corks to make its products
millions of customers rave about this
product and two-thirds of soul customers
have two or more pairs of footbeds
they take a little bit of getting used
to the structure under the arch is
unusual but once you get used to them
they provide great support for your feet
which is
probably particularly important if you
are mostly walking on highly structured
highly flat
and hard surfaces
and while the shoes look terrific if
you're just looking for foot beds to try
to make shoes that you already own be
healthier for your feet try the sole
footbed seriously try them they're
amazing
also they make a flip-flop that isn't a
flip-flop if you're a fan of a shoe that
you can quickly slip on to step outside
if it's wet or dirty but don't want the
downsides of a flip-flop slippery having
to grip with your toes to stay in it
which isn't good for your feet then this
is the flip-flop for you i was as i said
out paddle boarding for the first time
this season last week and i paddle board
barefoot
but getting to and from the water from
the car requires something comfortable
and protective walking over some jagged
rocks and such that you can slip on and
off seoul's highly structured flip-flop
they've got several i have the baja is
perfect for this job
so seoul has an amazing offer for
first-time customers of 50 off through
yourself.com darkhorse so you can try
soil for yourself that's y-o-u-r-s-o-l-e
dot com darkhorse they are so confident
you will love them that they also offer
a 90-day money-back guarantee it's very
hard to go wrong and this offer is
applicable to all items on the sole
store be it footbeds or footwear
all right
our second sponsor this week is alform a
company that makes absolutely terrific
custom sofas and i know
that the folks at home are asking
themselves what makes them so terrific
and it's two things
first it is unmitigated awesomeness
second it is the things i'm about to
describe
for a fraction of the cost of
traditional sofas you can customize size
layout fabric and color they do arm
chairs and love seeds all the way up to
an eight-seat sectional sofa which i am
eager to see one day
you can start small and buy more seats
later on without needing to get a whole
new sofa all form sofas are delivered
directly to your home free fast free and
fast and assembly is easy i can vouch
for that
we've got a beautiful sectional all-form
sofa in whiskey leather it's soft and
supple and warm unlike a lot of leather
we all pile on it to watch movies some
evenings it looks gorgeous and is
incredibly inviting and comfortable a
rare combination we like it so much we
got a second one
also easy to assemble also delivered to
us at home
uh listeners uh asked if all form holds
up to pets well yes it does the leather
that all form uses is 20 thicker than
typical furniture leather and it shows
nowhere despite the fact that both cats
and dogs lie on the couch many evenings
and if you prefer fabric all form
fabrics are three and a half times more
durable than the industry standard for
heavy duty fabrics so their fabrics are
going to hold up really well with pets
also
finally they offer a forever warranty
literally forever to find your perfect
sofa check out allform.com
darkhorse all form is offering 20 off
all orders for our listeners at
allform.com
darkhorse
and our third sponsor this week is md
hearing aid
everyone can empathize with what it
feels like to be left out of a
conversation that others are enjoying
but hearing loss is largely invisible to
those of us without it
md hearing aid was founded by an ent
surgeon who saw how many of his patients
needed hearing aids but couldn't afford
them he made it his mission to develop a
quality hearing aid that anyone could
afford he recognized that about 95 of
people who need a hearing aid only
require a few settings so he removed
some components that are not needed by
most people and cut out the middleman
now md hearing aid makes a rechargeable
hearing aid that is fda registered and
costs a small fraction of what typical
hearing aids cost
these hearing aids aim to fit so well
that no one will know you're wearing
them the rechargeable batteries last up
to 30 hours their volt plus model is
water resistant and up to three feet of
water and you don't need a prescription
you buy it directly from the source
where audiologists and licensed hearing
specialists are available seven days a
week
here's a testimonial from a friend of
ours who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids we asked
her to try this product and this is what
she said
with my particular type of hearing loss
a deep male voice in a noisy room is the
hardest situation for me to hear and
understand speech i wore the md hearing
aid to have a conversation with a deep
voiced man a room with a lot of white
noise
the md hearing aid passed the test as my
conversation partner's voice was clear
and understandable at a price point of
under a thousand dollars i was amazed at
how effective it is
md hearing it has brought affordable
hearing to over 600 000 satisfied
customers plus they offer a 45-day
risk-free trial with a hundred percent
money-back guarantee
so get clinic level care for 80 less
with md hearing aid go to md hearing
aid.com and use promo code darkhorse to
get their buy one get one 299
dollar
each when you buy a paired deal
every time i read that i pick up on it
plus they are adding a free extra
charging case a 100 value just for
listeners of darkhorse so head to
mdhearingaid.com and use our promo code
darkhorse or you can even call them at
1-833-772-1392 that's md hearing aid md
hearing aids effectively fight white
noise supremacy
okay that one's good yes
that one was good
i think it's a good thing i didn't go
into advertising and we all know it uh
for many reasons yeah it probably would
have been highly lucrative but um
and also effective as a mechanism of
torture which i am not in favor of no
you are not
okay um you wanted to actually start
with a correction from last week because
i understand it yes i did actually
before we do that can i just say one
thing about uh
the situation of ads on youtube and
i would like to point out that we when
we started doing ad reads which we were
reluctant to do and we made a commitment
to read only
ads for things that we actually
believe in
we also made the
agreement with ourselves that we would
make very clear when we were speaking as
a result of a a financial agreement with
a sponsor
hence the green border and the sound
that connotes that we are now in that
part of the podcast
youtube has taken to labeling podcasts
that contain
uh
paid sponsors with an icon which they
awkwardly place over things in a way
that disrupts and i think actually is in
its own way a kind of accusation
now in principle i like the idea
obviously we wouldn't have generated our
own mechanism for highlighting when
we're uh
i know that so youtube youtube asks
whether or not you contain sponsored
content and then it puts this icon on on
the videos
um but
the point is i find something troubling
about the fact that youtube is now doing
this to us despite the fact that we
voluntarily did it showing that we're
not trying to hide anything we're making
this very clear because we believe it's
part of being uh credible and honest
about how how we make a living but
youtube has also
demonetized both of our channels which
was a massive hit
eliminated more than half of our family
income has refused to reinstate us for
essentially
doing what we trained to do trying to
make sense of complex systems in public
and so in any case i just want to point
out that our videos are now double
labeled because youtube labels them on
top of our self labeling
and that people should should note that
that's the kind of place
youtube is well and you can you can
therefore
also be assured the reason that we
wanted to have both a border around the
the sponsors and a tone coming at the
both the beginning and the end was so
that you can be absolutely sure that if
um at the point that you were looking at
us listening to us talk and there's no
green border around what we're saying um
that this is a hundred percent the
conclusions that we have come to with no
financial incentives at all right that
there is that there uh it is no
sponsored content that is cryptic in our
stuff right
which is very important if you think
about how we ended up here right you and
i were
driven from professions that we were
very good at college professors
so suddenly jobs that seemed very secure
and provided all of the income for our
family
were no longer tenable we
carved out a second way of making a
living in the universe this one much
harder to do in many ways because
you know the architecture for how you
put together a podcast that people will
actually pay attention to
isn't simple but we did it and then
youtube
uh
rendered us incapable of using their
mechanism and so we you know we we were
already reading content but
we have no choice this is a primary
mechanism by which this content is uh
um is supported
and in any case i just want to point out
uh youtube's rather backward view of the
universe and i guess probably well it's
i mean it's perfectly analogous in the
way that you have just described it um
in terms of one career
from which you and to some degree we
were chased out by a woke mob and a
second career
where big tech is trying to cancel us by
virtue of you know woke 2.0 you know
it woke medically welcome you're in your
framing
um and in neither case you know that
there
there are ways uh to reduce our reach
and our impact but there are not
but that is not going to work to cause
us to change what we say when we find
errors
in what we said we come back to you and
we tell them and we tell you and we're
constantly looking to falsify what it is
that we understand about the universe
especially when it does
run uh run afoul of or is just different
from what the mainstream is telling us
is true right okay so good and i haven't
put that together but you're right this
is the second version of woke once again
interrupting our ability to earn in the
universe in a in a universe where people
apparently do want to hear what we have
to say we were very popular in the
classroom you know there was you know we
always had overflowing classrooms with
waiting lists always i believe every
single quarter that either one of us
taught that was the case
and you know despite
what i would argue as interference by
youtube
and
an inexplicable flatness of the growth
of our channel we detect in the world
that lots of people are interested in
what we have to say so in any case this
will come back at the end of the podcast
when we talk about the possibility of a
gen x um revolution but for the moment i
just thought it was gen x being the
uh the generation to which we
i guess at this point proudly belong i
know you know what i actually i don't
like i don't like
appointing the word proud to immutable
characteristics um i i have objected to
this in the past so um you know we we
had no say in the moment at which we
were born any more than we had any say
in what sex we were born or what our
lineage uh had been uh so
uh you can be proud of things that the
people born of the same era like you
have done um but that that is not the
same thing yeah i i will i take a
different approach here yeah i am proud
af of being a gen x for reasons i could
not possibly defend as a result of the
logic you just deployed so anyway we
will get back there what the hell is gen
x how many of us are actually in the
world it's not a lot um
but anyway are we about to become uh
important in a new way i sure hope so
let's talk about it at the end of the
podcast okay
oh correction yes okay
um so
last week we had a
somewhat extensive discussion about the
recently released but long discussed
together trial
a trial
of several different drugs there were
several different arms to the study
one of them was about ivermectin and its
effectiveness for
covid
and
we learned seven months ago that the
conclusion of the study was that
ivermectin was ineffective but we waited
seven months to see the methods and
there was a feature of what was finally
published in the new england journal of
medicine that caught several of us off
guard including me it looked as if a
bunch of people had mysteriously
disappeared from the placebo group
turns out that was not correct so what i
said last week is not in fact an error
in the way that we thought it was
that said
there are
several groups that i'm aware of one of
which i'm a participant in that are
looking deeply into the together trial
and it is amazing how many uh features
of the method seem non-standard and
potentially
dangerous i won't say more but
not not just
the method as it was described in
advance but the method as it plays out
in real time as it plays out in real
life as it is actually applied like the
method that they claim to have used
doesn't seem to be the method they broke
they broke with method in several places
right now the one thing i want to point
out here in addition to the correction
which i believe is necessary and i think
we've been very careful to make
corrections when we've gotten things
wrong which is inevitable and in this
case we weren't the only people who got
this wrong because it was the obvious
interpretation even though it was not
the correct interpretation
but
i'm now watching
a group of something like 10 people
some of them absolutely experts in this
exact location whether it be experts in
how clinical trials are run experts in
medicine and the treatment of covid i'm
watching these folks grapple with simply
understanding what happened
right
this is what was done according to the
manuscript that is supposed to be
a a recipe for replication
right a recipe for replication and we
are approximately a zillion miles from
enough information to replicate the
trial right we are still grappling with
understanding even what happened and not
in trivial ways in ways that are
absolutely central to whether or not the
conclusions of the study mean what they
claim to mean and i must say that that
is jaw-dropping let's assume that it's
honest in origin we cannot have science
where
10 smart people who know what you need
to know to understand what happened
cannot unpack the simple description of
how the
study was done right that should never
be the case because as you and i know
from having written dissertations
it is incredibly common that if you look
at the title and the abstract of the
paper and then you look at the methods
that you discover that actually the
title and the abstract are not justified
by what was done right yeah so so
the the claim about what has been
learned is uh
not
found in the actual science that was
done it was not is not found in the
actual science and you know there are
places where this can actually happen to
you honestly right like places where you
submit an abstract to a conference for
work you're doing the work will be done
by the time you present it and the point
is your abstract is a pretty good guess
at what you will present but you may
discover that it's not exactly in fact
um uh charles handley who was one of my
bat mentors uh used to say may all your
abstracts come true um so just i mean
we've talked about this before here but
just the way that academic
academic communication one of the ways
that academic communication happens like
the first
pass especially for um especially for
young researchers and especially for
research that people think is going to
be very important
has been at least in the past this may
actually be changing with social media
frankly but it has been until very
recently
the conference right so there are annual
conferences for all of you know all of
the major organizations and you can
parse it in lots of different ways you
know it can be organism you know over in
our space it could be evolution it could
be animal behavior it could be you know
molecular biology it can be you know
mammal specific it can be lots of
different ways
but you have to
submit an abstract to be accepted or
rejected for um to be able to give a
talk at a conference many many months um
sometimes well more than half a year in
advance of actually giving the talk and
very often the field season during which
or you know or the or the lab work for
us it was always field season but the
field season during which you're
actually going to be doing the work that
you're hoping to talk about hasn't yet
happened so you have to take a guess and
this this also is the case for um
permits like i found i found myself in
madagascar
arguing in bad french with some
bureaucrat about um
my inability to explain to him exactly
what i was going to learn in the next
five months which is the reason that i
was trying to get permits to study these
frogs it's like you know if i already
knew i wouldn't be here i wouldn't need
to be doing the research um so you know
there are a lot of these
um you know bureaucratic solutions
uh in order to make scheduling easier in
order to make paperwork easier um that
reveal a just a like a tragic
misunderstanding of what discovery is
and of what science is
right and so there are organic ways that
your abstract can be a mismatch for what
your study produces
this one ain't that right not only was
this a paper published in the standard
way in a high
profile journal
right with top tier editors
presumably top tier peer reviewers but
it's delayed
by seven months in an environment where
things have been rushed this one was
delayed and so the point is the number
of opportunities for somebody to say
what they were
scientifically obligated to say which is
we can't tell what you did
right you may have done
what was necessary to get to that
conclusion but it damn well better be in
the methods section and if you know
smart people can't figure it out from
what you said then that's on you
so smart people some of whom are
specialists in exactly the fields
for whom they should be this is a second
language right um can't are having a
hard time figuring it out so they're
having a hard time figuring it out that
is
that is
a technique
used in some cases by some scientists in
both writing and speaking
in order to sound like they are smart
but not actually um interested in being
understood right it is it can be an
obscuring technique um i do not um
i am not claiming that's what's going on
here and it certainly sounds like even
if there is any of that it's a whole lot
of other things as well um but the idea
that
scientists need not
focus on communicating what it is that
they have learned is
is archaic and regressive and wrong and
it may be that some scientists um need
not think about what it is that their
you know that their message would be to
the outside world like that's what
science journalists are for
excuse me but
being able to communicate what it is
that you've done and what it is that you
think you've learned and what it is that
you think it means are absolutely
necessary parts of the scientific
process
necessary parts of the scientific
process that as soon as they fail what
you are doing is not science right the
philosophy of science depends on these
things being done correctly so that
somebody else can figure out i mean the
fact is we're all not good at figuring
out every error that we make right
sometimes we catch them sometimes we
don't so the point is built into this
whole mechanism
is the ability to for others to
scrutinize what you did if we can't even
figure out what it was then we can't get
to the stage where we say well okay does
that result in your conclusion being
robust is there a confound what younger
people call confounders
that you know you should have spotted
that may have been important
i i think i've said this before but i
actually believe the younger people are
right to call them confounders um i just
think it's linguistically more correct
than what we say but it sure sounds
wrong to me
um
all right anyway
that's the long and short of it i would
say people should be paying i should say
there's a clock ticking as i understand
it that there is a retraction clock
that if you're going to request that a
journal retract a study that has
published in this case there's a short
window to do it and so
in this case because this journal has a
shorter than the average window or
because this paper has been given a
shorter than average window for the
journal i believe it is the journal's
policy but the point is that clock is
short relative to the amount of effort
that a large group of smart
well-informed people need in order to
figure out even what was done let alone
whether it
reaches the conclusion naturally so
anyway this is you know i'm sure
that if the
paper any paper turns out to be nonsense
after that clock has expired the new
england journal of medicine has a
mechanism for retracting it but the
point is to request the retraction they
have very severe limits on how much you
can say and how long you have to say it
you know
which may be more bureaucratic solutions
uh for problems that don't necessarily
fit into bureaucratic rules but i i also
understand the constraint right like you
know you would need you know just like
the statute of limitations for you know
for for crimes
there needs to be limits so that people
can't come back and and you know we
would definitely see especially you know
as the you know trans activists would be
asking for all sorts of things to be
retracted now right but okay so i have
argued in many places uh including lots
of stuff in and around game b
that um
a complex system that is well managed a
human system
has to be
uh well managed with discretion right
you need individuals with just
discretion so to the extent that there
might be a clock for a standard thing
there ought to be a way to send an email
to the editor and say in this case the
clock shouldn't apply because there's
too much resting on it and the
complexity of the methods is too great
for us
to be expected to meet that a request
for an extension sure
um
okay are we there i think we are there
yeah um before i start talking a little
bit about uh
about the next thing i want to say that
one of the effects of the glorious
weather that we had this week and then
today it was hailing so i don't know i
don't know what's going on it's spring
in the pacific northwest um is the
amount of pollen
is unbelievable we are surrounded here
uh
gratefully uh we are in the forest and
so we have a certain amount of the
evergreens for which washington state is
named for which the college that we were
once tenured at was named um things like
western red cedars and doug furs and
noble furs and
and such and um and others no pines um
but a lot of a lot of those but and and
uh but white right now we've got um the
most common
deciduous tree sometimes called a big
leaf tree broadleaf broadleaf tree i
guess uh is a big leaf maple and we've
got a lot of them here
it's a periodical green
it's a periodical green yeah it's
deciduous which is also known as
periodical
um
and they are just they are they're horny
this week they are having a lot of
pollen
the male bits yeah we don't know about
the females i haven't asked yeah i
haven't i didn't ask the men either
the men trees didn't need to they no i
don't i should not i should not play
with the word man like that but i didn't
ask the male trees either but here they
are in you know everything every surface
i was i put my hand down on a windowsill
like oh and our beautiful black cat is
coming inside his toes yellow his brump
yellow so we have a anyway this little
in the throat is about pollen right now
well i actually i'm going to pat myself
on the back here physiologically for you
you could but that's weird here's the
thing um i have had pretty severe
allergies and we are having a hell of a
pollen season yes we are um
so far i got it under control you know
this this this is of course a
conversation that could go lots and lots
of places but you know i know i never
had seasonal allergies at all
and uh just in the last couple of years
i you know i don't i'm not sneezing my
eyes aren't watering particularly but i
definitely feel it in my throat which is
where anything will go when it when i
get got
any kind of pathogen or your immune
system thinks it's a pathogen and it's
going to go after it even though it
shouldn't um so that that is interesting
because really we had every window in
the house thrown open for both the
perfectly glorious day and the slightly
cooler day that preceded it and as a
result uh pretty much everything in the
house is yellow now it's all coated in
pollen it's all it is all coated in part
yeah um i i will just mention that uh
after i had had covid in our recent bout
i had lingering stuff for a long time uh
i thought it might be long covered it
may have been uh a little bit of long
coat it's a medium covered but at some
point
um
the symptoms that i had experienced when
i was still eating wheat that i had not
known were symptoms of a wheat allergy
started coming back and i was kind of
ignoring it and then the symptom that is
the most conspicuous to me it's not the
worst symptom by far but
the numb hands when i'm sleeping
came back and it was like okay wait a
minute am i eating wheat somewhere that
i don't know and i started eliminating
things that had shown up
you know in the right time frame that
they could plausibly have been
and nothing nothing nothing until
finally
i cut out all of the supplements that we
have been taking um
to prevent covet and other diseases dc
magnesium zinc right
and i got better very quickly and i
think i think what happened is i was
stuck in a
inflammation system one of those
supplements has something in it well i'm
pretty sure i'm i'm hesitant to test
this because it's going to involve me if
i'm right it's going to involve me
messing myself up again but
what happens and it's not the first time
i've been here you think a supplement
doesn't have any wheat because it
doesn't say wheat anywhere on the label
but unless it says something like
certified gluten-free which in my case
is a weird thing because i don't think
it's gluten as we've talked about here
before it's a it's some other molecule
in wheat
unless it says that if it says something
like vegetable um
um
gelatin
right that is to say gelatin of a
non-animal origin
that can contain wheat without them
saying the word and so i don't know if
that's what happened but it turned out
that the vitamin d of which i was taking
a substantial amount does say
vegetable gelatin on it and so anyway
i'm now in the uncomfortable position of
scientifically the right thing to do is
to go back on it and see what happens
um but from the point of view of like
living a life it does it's not an
exciting prospect to me right
well and at least um from the
perspective of but what are you going to
do for your d levels we're now in the
time of year when uh we can when
the sun is high enough in the sky for
enough hours a day that you can actually
generate d here um in at what are we at
40
i don't know exactly what our latitude
is actually that's strange but it's 40
something it is oh yeah it's 40
something for sure i want to say 45 46
i'm not actually sure i may be off by a
couple of degrees
um
but i guess it's over um any place over
35 degrees north or south of 35 degrees
south there's some period of the year
when um the sun is simply never high
enough in the sky on any given on any
day
for you know some some days weeks or
months in the winter that you can
generate d at all but we are um we are
out of that period now and it's warming
up and at least you don't need the d in
order to have the d in your system yeah
now for those of you wondering
about what this means about where you
live i
we have recommended and i'm going to
recommend even more strongly an app
called d minder
d minder allows you to know when in the
year you can start making vitamin d when
in the day you can start and when it is
no longer possible based on your
location it allows you to integrate
things about your own physiology anyway
it's a very it's a little bit difficult
to understand but it is worth investing
the time in this thing so i just went on
it for the first time
after i was out for you know two hours
on the water like okay let's let's see
what that means you know for
for me and yeah you can plug in a whole
lot of stuff about your age and your
weight and your height and because you
know the the heavier you are the heavier
set you are um the slower your d
acquisition um and the older you are the
slower your d acquisition and the darker
your skin the slower your de-acquisition
and there are some other things too but
you don't need to include any of that
right um the the thing that it can tell
you that is like clear simple
quantitative data
uh is just tell it where you are and it
will know therefore um what your
latitude is doesn't care about longitude
and um well it doesn't care about
longitude with regard to d but also if
you tell it exactly where you are with
regard to latitude and longitude it'll
tell you
it should be able to figure out or you
should tell it how high you are your
altitude because
basically the less atmosphere between
you and the sun the faster you make d as
well
and of course the faster you burn so
there's a trade-off always
but
having a sense of okay given where i am
and what day of the year it is
what is the you know is there a window
in which i could be making d from the
sun and what is it and it's useful okay
one last thing here um what i think we
have learned as we have built up our
understanding on d is that
supplementation is important for people
who live above a certain latitude
because we're almost all deficient
in the part of the year
right but
supplementation is not a great
replacement for self-made photosynthetic
vitamin d that's right and so the point
is one of the things that this i was
looking at this app when i was out on my
bike ride
i was looking at when in the year you
can start making it turns out to be the
day before my birthday february 20th is
for portland the day you can start
making vitamin d how much can you make
very little how much are you likely to
make almost none why because february is
cold and so you even if you go outside
and even if it's sunny both of which you
know are
iffy at any given moment in portland
the
chances that you'll make substantial
vitamin d or very low the number of the
idea being because it's cold you're
covered up right and so you know the
more of your skin is exposed the more
vitamin d you're making right so in any
case we are something like a hundred
days into our uh
no no
50 45 45 or 50 days into a
200. and i have to look at the app to
figure out exactly how many total days
there are but the point is
knowing
if the point is you want to make vitamin
d that your you will then store in
adipose tissue which will then be
released over the winter when you can't
make vitamin d
right then the point is well there's a
clock ticking in terms of how long you
have to do it and in fact the clock in
which it's practical to do it is pretty
short because it's when the sun is
shining it's warm enough for you not to
be overly covered up and knowing that is
a is a power tool with respect to
um
total vitamin d you can produce
absolutely and i mean i was thinking
about this too it's it's it's been a
trope
uh for a long time that you know people
old people on the east coast um go to
florida in the winter right and
you know we grew up we grew up in la
which actually it turns out is at a
latitude where you can make d all year
round uh which i didn't know until i
looked at this app right
um
but the idea and you know and lots of
people who aren't old um
who you know may or may not be spending
the entire winters in florida uh will
vacation in in the caribbean in florida
for a week and you know we we know that
it feels good i mean this isn't
something that we ourselves have done
but you know we've done similar things
um
you know
obviously when it's cold out and you're
stuck inside and it's gray and it's dark
what you're craving is a blast of heat
and blue sky and just ease right but
it's that is partially
your body telling you you need this this
is good for you this is healthy for you
and it's it's novel in that to go from a
place where you're making no d at all
and therefore if you're caucasian you're
probably really really white and the
first day you go out you're going to get
burned and then the rest of your
vacation is going to be kind of
miserable because you got burned the
first day so you have to be much more
careful than you would be if you were in
a place that had just a fluctuating
level of d with a fluctuating height of
uh the sun in the sky over over the year
you have to be more intentional about
your exposure as you first begin to get
exposed as i did you know on this
on this just you know two two and a half
hours out on the water um but it was the
first time that my shoulders had seen
the sun in i don't know five months it's
a long time
and
um
it just it reminds me that even many of
our modern cultural things that seem
cute
not very serious
may well be driven by our bodies
actually informing us of what they need
yeah
and actually this will come up as we get
into some of the other content here but
you know
there is a way in which
uh
tan
for a caucasian person tan looks
healthier right
um
that may be about something and we may
have gone through a long period in which
frankly what we now should understand is
paranoia over sun exposure it's not that
sun exposure causes cancer it's that sun
burns cause cancer and you can have sun
exposure without a sunburn right
learning to modulate that may be a key
skill for
life
and you know and this has huge
implications also
for
things
flu is much less of a deal in the
tropics right why
well vitamin d production
is uh
possible all year round okay well that's
good
why did
kovid hit so hard in uh was it guayaquil
in guayaquil if it's in the tropics in a
place you know it's near the equator
right well right yeah guy kill is really
unpleasantly hot and humid and so i'm
not saying that this is what happened
but my hypothesis about what happened in
guayaquil would be that the capacity to
make vitamin d was overwhelmed by people
acquiring air conditioners which
dehumidify and cool buildings and in
that hot sticky environment if you're
not just sort of condemned to hot and
sticky and you get used to it and you
stop noticing it but there's a place to
retreat that's cool and drier right
people will tend to do it so what i
would love to know and the prediction of
the hypothesis
is that actually there's vitamin d
deficiency in guayaquil that
for example didn't
doesn't
match what there is in keto which is at
high altitude is naturally cooler and
drier is a great place to make vitamin d
because it's less atmosphere between
between you and the sun
so anyway these are all parsable
questions but the fact that there is
generally less of this issue in the
tropics right with interesting
exceptions suggested a pattern to be
learned from yeah um
boy we're going a lot of places we
didn't we didn't think we would go but
this brings up something else i was
thinking about this week actually um i
had
in the last few weeks two different
women
both of whom i know a little bit
both of whom
um are very skilled in some areas um you
know they're they're smart in in the
domains that they are that they're good
in
um but i made a comment to each of them
separately and i was reminded of this um
because another one of these the second
one just happened yesterday
about
um
well having been up um in the san juan
islands when we were signing copies of
our book for for darville's on orcas
and said well you know of course
it's even darker up there in the winter
the days are even shorter than they are
here
and she said oh really
and i had a very similar interaction
with another woman in a totally
different domain
a few weeks ago and i thought
i don't i'm actually shocked that people
are walking around the world not
with an ability to know that there are
different places on the earth and not
recognizing some of the very simple
patterns that you could know about
whether or not if you know if you're
farther north if you're in the northern
hemisphere
and you're in place a and your friend is
in place b a thousand miles north their
winters are going to be darker their
days are going to be shorter and around
the equinox you're going to hit
equilibrium and there and then they're
probably never going to get quite as hot
as you but their days are going to start
getting longer than yours
until at the solstice at the summer
solstice their days are going to be a
lot longer than yours and then it's
going to start sliding back again
towards the equinox at which point
they're going to be equal again and you
know i could i remember actually going
into one of the few times i went and was
like okay i'll i'll teach one of our
boys elementary school classes for a day
as you're often asked to
and um
i
i took in like styrofoam balls with
sticks through them and had this had the
kids like third grade hold them at 23
degree angles and um try to get them to
understand the path around the sun and
it was a little much you know the boys
were using them as swords and
it was chaos but it was it was fine
um so i'm not i think it was a little
bit complex for a third grade classroom
but um
but we used to do this we used to do i
was just going to say okay go for it we
used to we used to both of us in the
classes we taught together and in the
classes we taught separately
try to get our college students to
unpack
issues both what is the pattern of let's
say
moon phases
right
how exactly does it work and you know i
remember we we put together a long
questionnaire oh yeah that had a bunch
of questions some of them are quite
tough just thinking about that maybe
i'll post that on substance you know the
tides are um the result of uh
lunar gravitation why are there two high
tides every day rather than one right
that's that that's a really good
question right but we used to do this
and the basic
look i think the thing is
a person
who had a natural relationship with
knight
would be aware of the moon phase
right they would be aware of the moon
phase because you would detect it often
enough that you would
the pattern would trigger you right if
your night
existence is primarily indoors right
you know and you're not counting time
this way because you have artificial
time counters that tell you exactly when
in the year you are and things like that
yes um
then you know you're just you're
divorced from it likewise your
awareness of how daylight you know i i
think our day length changed perceptibly
even in our move from olympia to
portland yeah which is just a hundred
miles right it's not a long move but yes
no it no i agree our
our summer solstice night is not quite
as long not quite as long and our
winters are not quite as hard to deal
with right because the the day length
also changes most slowly around the
solstice
it's all star social sciences yeah um
another another thing that we um is not
as easy to pay attention to because
we're living so much inside which is
also about seasonality is phenology um
not phrenology
but phonology
um spelled the same way except for that
missing r so uh you know phrenology
being the uh gosh what even is it like
pretending to be able to tell people's
something from the shape of their head i
don't even know um but phenology
which um
i think
gosh i want to say benjamin franklin
maybe i just one of the early american
uh important american dudes
paid a lot of attention to basically the
timing
of
flowering and fruiting and usually it's
about plants but also to some degree
about about animals so you know when is
the first onset of
huckleberry bud when is the first
huckleberry berry in citrus huckleberry
berry um in in a particular place when
do for instance i i think this would fit
into the same kind of thing you know
when
do
uh the migrant hummingbirds come back
when do you see your first hummingbird
each year and so because people have
cared about this because it's a way to
keep in touch with what's outside your
window and to get you outside your
window and to spend time outside and
because it has very real um practical
applications for things like like
farming for agriculture
we have many you know centuries actually
of of records at least well over a
century of records for many places and
that has been how we're able to see what
is happening as seasonal changes are
happening in some places phenologies are
changing and we can see this in part by
looking at museum records and at
people's personal like just journals
like ah you know i'm gonna make
something up for some random place like
oh it's april 2nd and i saw my you know
and i saw my first huggleberry bud today
all right well i'll be way too late for
here but one interesting thing
i am
certain
that the introduction of non-native
species invasives that actually succeed
will change the phenology
of
native species
because one of the things about
phenology that's really fascinating
is that
plants tend to spread out
plants that are animal dependent tend to
spread out they're fruiting and
flowering because they are playing
spread out in time
right because if you imagine let's
imagine that you've got a bunch of
flowers
that use the same pollinator if they all
flower at the same time a they're in
competition for the services of that
pollinator right and better not to be in
competition but b
think about this in terms of
uh satiation b
be
right
spelling
but the point is uh if
if you have a a population of a
pollinator and there's nothing for it
right you'll get starvation the number
of that pollinator will drop and so what
you want it's classic lotka volterra
dynamics which is uh which is the
classic ecology which is probably too
simple but you know predator prey
dynamics where prey numbers rise so
predator numbers rise and then as the
predators
eat too many of the prey such as the
parade numbers can't crash then so too
after a short delay to the predator
numbers crash right and so in the case
of a bunch of plants that have no
interest in each other or may actually
be competitors for each other uh at the
level of competing for light or
something
having a predator a uh pollinator
population that is always fed and
therefore doesn't crash is actually in
all of their interests and so anyway you
get this repulsion across the calendar
so that things flower and through it at
different times so that they're not in
competition with each other and so that
the uh the animals that they depend on
don't
starve to death
and so if you introduce something that
succeeds in your environment and it fits
somewhere in the calendar in its home
phonology right then the point is okay
well now that changes the calculation
for all the native things and where they
should be so my guess would be well if
it attracts native pollinators if the if
the outsider attracts native pollinators
then
the native uh plants have to have to
work the way around it yes exactly so
anyway it's a it would be a really cool
uh frankly i don't know whether it's
been studied or how extensively but it'd
be really interesting to plot out you
know i mean exactly as you said one
prediction is that
a
an invasive that doesn't use native
pollinators is unlikely to have this
effect on the other hand
it's not that no you know there's plants
that have multiple dispersal and
strategies so it could be something you
know if it's not using a native
pollinator what is it using if it has a
home pollinator that's an animal
how is it reproducing
so if it's an invasive it probably is
using the local
well if it's vanilla and madagascar it
is using the local people to hand
pollinate each individual
uh being on that orchid um okay that's
that's a conversation
yes um but maybe i'll i'll just i'll
condense this so i was thinking about uh
i was thinking about
the phrase this week
that is so common now
among among people um you know you need
you need to teach children how to think
not what to think what we should be
doing in college is teaching how to
think not what to think it's something
that we used to say not so much in our
classrooms but we gave a couple of
um talks at evergreens like come figure
out what you're interested in days um as
i remember they always put us in the
farthest room like at the bottom of a
dark staircase with the missing stairs
and still the rooms were filled but we
like we we used to invoke this right
because it seems once you hear it it
seems obvious and
um
and yes also there needs to be a basis
and i have heard some conservative
mostly conservative pushback on like now
there needs to be a framework upon which
you can um ask the questions but um
my sense has always been actually that
comes like if if you put the what
forward uh then you often never get to
the how and if you put the how forward
in in education uh you will end up
interspersing the what in a lot of
places yeah and also you know
it would be really challenging to teach
the how without it resulting in the what
the point is the what is the natural
consequence of getting the how right
i i think so and certainly we had um i
believe excellent success doing it that
way i have heard i i do hear murmurings
and even louder than that from again
largely um conservatives who
who want what they view as a more
traditional approach to education um i
don't i don't think they're right i'm
sure they're not right at the college
level i do wonder if there's sort of an
age at which well there are some topics
and we've we talked about this in the
school chapter and the childhood chapter
of of our book there are some topics
which you're not going to be able to
educate yourself in um
likely by obs by simple observation you
know things like um calculus yeah
i i don't believe
that any of us who've used um teach
students how to think not what to think
actually mean
don't don't have a what right don't
include there's lots of what but yeah
the point is
the what is the consequence of a how
and
you can teach material
so you're arguing with me as if this is
my position i am telling you for sure
that this is a position that is out
there right and i don't full i don't
understand like i don't agree with it
nor do i fully understand it so it's
going to it's really going to be just
frustrating for you to sort of argue
with me i'm like i agree with you but
absolutely i know that let's say there
are people who say no actually the
fundamentals first
right right and you need some
fundamentals right you know you're not
gonna be able to figure out how a cell
works without somebody saying that's the
mitochondria and here's what it does um
but let's i think i think the thing is
the it's like you know
when we were talking about this you and
i were talking about it earlier this
week there are lots of things like you
know the government that governs best
governs least
which yes if you
take
a narrow understanding of it suggests no
government is good but that's of course
not what it means at all right and so
this is one of those things it doesn't
mean don't tell them what it means
that
well but lit i mean literally
the phrase is teach children how to
think now what to think
so uh i get i mean i think that's that's
what people hear because that's
literally the words so let's just let's
let's go there okay what i learned this
week are actually what i was reminded of
this week and i thought i was learning
it but it turns out i knew it back in
1990
um is that that phrase i believe
originated or at least i i as far as i
can tell originated with margaret mead
in her 1928 book coming of age in samoa
and i found you know this is this is the
copy that i had in my intro to cultural
anthropology class
because after going through a number of
majors i ended up as an anthro i ended
up with a degree in anthropology
and i have in this book so i've since
now gone through and started book
darting it that's a modern modern thing
but i used to underline in books which i
don't do anymore and i find here my
underlining from
1990 i think the children must be taught
how to think not what to think in her
very final chapter education for choice
and one of her positions in here is that
um
modern societies as she as she refers to
them
have all of this choice
and that that's a good thing but we have
to understand that it comes with
challenges and that in a society like
samoa she argues
because there is so much less choice it
is easier to have something to have a
culture that is sort of you know all of
a type which of course makes sense once
you hear it said that way
now i will say
um
i will say that
mead has taken a hit like a big hit of
late um and not even that recently it's
been it's been a few decades now where
um
basically
uh a lot of anthropologists decided that
they didn't want to pay attention to her
is how i sort of understood the story um
and we're looking for ways to
i don't know like
deep six her like you know something i
don't know
she was retcanned
retcanned yeah retroactively cancelled
cool yes she was rhett cannes so mead or
the attempt was made to ret can her
retroactively cancel her because i the
fact is that uh you know she's she is
still understood to be one of you know
she was she was a woman working in a
field where there weren't many women in
an era when ethnography was being done
but was um was also
always done always communicated and very
highfaluting terms that were not
communicated well to the public because
that was not the point and this book
coming of age and samoa she actually
specifies in an introduction that she
later writes that it was the first book
that she intentionally wrote it with the
intention of it being and it turns out
it was the first time it had been done
of writing a scholarly work in an excess
inaccessible prose so that's
extraordinary right
she wrote in english in a field where
the lingua franca
lingua franca was jargon yeah
exactly she wrote that's perfect she
wrote in english it wasn't perfectly
said i kind of you know well no but so
i'll say it again and i'll probably
stumble on the same thing she wrote it
she wrote
she wrote margaret mead wrote coming of
age in samoa in english
um in a field in which the lingua franca
was jargon
well done
yeah there we are but um so someone so
i'm i don't have all the details in my
head right now uh someone who came of
age himself if you will um reading mead
uh wanting to become an anthropologist
um many many years later like i think in
the 70s uh maybe went back went himself
as a as a proto-anthropologist
seeking to do ethnography uh went back
to samoa in order to um you know see
this amazing culture and interact with
and and again do some ethnography uh and
and very quickly he reports i think um
found an informant or maybe it was to
um from when mead had been there so by
now very very old
who said you know and mostly she was
talking to teenage girls because she was
doing coming-of-age work and she is a
woman herself had greater access to the
girls than the boys um and so she found
an informant or two that had been one of
mead's informants
who said
yeah you know those were really invasive
questions and i just was not i i'd never
thought about these kinds of questions
before so i just told her what i thought
you want to hear
now this um even if we take that at face
value as many in anthropology have done
and said ah well then you know
uh then you can't trust what those
informants said what the leap that is
then made is then you can't trust
anything in this book then you can't
trust me then you can't trust anything
that emerges from her thinking and those
are um those are erroneous logical leaps
so what you find in this book is a
certain amount of um
stuff that she's reporting from her
informants
honestly i
skimmed and re-read
much of this book this week i find that
now as i from my underlining if that's
any indication from back then some of
the least interesting parts of the book
it's her observations of cultural
happenings
and how she describes them and then also
the interpretation that she puts on them
as separate things
what is actually happening and then what
does she think it means those are the
places where she shines
and those don't hinge on what her
informants are telling her about how
they view their own sexuality right that
it it just doesn't so um i i am still
interested in mead as both an historical
and a scientific figure and in this book
as uh as you know especially her
thinking about uh education which his
entire final chapter is about and which
as it turns out is the source of this
thing that everyone's got on the tips of
their tongues now we should teach
children how to think not what to think
which
i once knew and i had forgotten and i
assume most people don't know that
that's from mead
a couple things um one
it is
taught in anthropology nobody assumes
that informants are speaking accurately
right everybody who understands human
beings knows that that is unlikely to be
perfectly true and may be totally false
and it is especially likely to be false
on sexual matters where human beings are
not typically all that honest right so
anyway it would be shocking if mead had
fallen into that and just simply assumed
that her informants were telling her
exactly right what they what they
thought right so this actually
this the whole rat canning thing rat
canning
retroactive cancellation retroactive
cancellation it's it's a genre it is a
genre oh yeah um and i you know
i think the thing is we've seen a bunch
of these cases and they're highly
relevant right
luke montagne
right retroactively canceled the
discoverer of hiv
canceled because he had some very
heterodox views on some other matters
including whether or not hiv is the
cause of aids where he initially
believed it was and came to believe it
wasn't similarly kerry mullis similarly
carrie mullis another uh nobel prize
winner uh who
has been
downgraded in people's estimation right
um
there there are many other examples i
mean you can start nap shag napoleon
with the yanomami
right i think this happened to us
as we sorted out uh
kovit in real time um so anyway i think
i think the thing is
it really troubles me actually it's one
thing if you discover that somebody has
engaged in a fraud right it's another
thing when somebody
is doing what they told you that they
were doing and you've changed your mind
about how you feel about that which i
think is what happened to us where it
was like oh people they loved us
heterodox when we were fighting the
first version of woke
um but then the point is we
we tread into sacred
territory and the point is actually
we're doing the same thing that we've
done all along and you've just decided
you don't like it this time yeah not
not trying to be heretics trying to see
what's real yeah
um
yeah indeed so
i will also mention and this actually
this is going to be something that i'll
write about in my natural selections
this week but in i believe that same
class where i was assigned coming of age
in samoa and read it back in 1990 1991
something
i also had this book which no one has
ever heard of and i can't even find
anywhere so i lent it out to a couple of
students at one point
a couple points and almost didn't get it
back it's like i treasure this book it's
also since been book started this is
coming of age in new jersey
written by an anthropologist michael
moffatt coming of age in new jersey
college and american culture and in it
he's a young anthropologist
uh hired at rutgers uh who decides to go
undercover in the rutgers dorms
and that rue as a you know he's 33 and
he's pretending to be a slightly older
freshman coming back to school for the
first time and this is in late 70s
and that only lasts through like
orientation like it only lasts a week or
so um but then
he he
a stays in touch with a bunch of the
kids that he met then and he spends um
two years
living
in the dorms but as an anthropologist as
a participant observant a rather
engaging in participant observation
um not pretending to be an undergrad um
both both then in the in the late 70s
and then again in the early mid 80s
and i read this book in the early 90s
and was reminded of dorm life from my
freshman year very much it struck me as
like okay this really the college
experience for so many weird kids is
precisely the coming-of-age
ceremony that
uh that we don't really have anymore and
um
i got you know i gotta fork you there's
two places i want to go the first one is
uh
john mcwhorter wrote an excellent op-ed
in the new york times this week on
whether or not
we should really be thinking that
everyone who's college age should be
going to college
and he says uh among many other things
and i'll again i'll link this in the
show notes quote
um and this this actually is an idea
from a former president of bard college
um an offshoot of which is simon's rock
which john mccarter went to as well
quote the idea that in our society the
ordinary trajectory after high school is
to attend another four years of school
has become arbitrary purposeless and
even absurd
and um that is certainly
that that is certainly true
and he asks in the book um in the
article
um
how many of the things that we are
interested in people doing actually
requires four years of college he
doesn't get into what you know anyone
who's familiar with his work knows to be
some of his other main criticisms indeed
his most recent book um called woke
racism
the idea that college may be actually
more harmful than good at all as you
know as opposed to this other argument
which is even if college is functioning
as it should
aren't there a lot of things that you
might be doing
that would be incredibly valuable both
for you and for society that could be um
could be better attained through
learning through
you know through apprenticeship for
instance um that's not a word he uses in
the in the article but
yeah well i must say at one level i feel
i have long since lost my patience with
the idea that this is debatable about
modern college right sure i think there
is a question about whether or not
college makes sense certainly you and i
experienced and many of our better
colleagues talked about the fact
that college had
become remedial right that effectively
for many people college is where they
learn things that prior generations
might have learned in high school
absolutely
and this is a point mcquarter makes also
yes so that is a very troubling fact
now as for it being a rite of passage i
agree and i think we talk about in our
book i agree that it's sort of the
closest thing that we've got but i think
it's fairer to say we actually don't
have a rite of passage
rites of passage are
crucial
in the sense that you have a
i i'm struggling for an alternative to
the word juvenile but you have
effectively a pre-adult program and it
is not synonymous with your adult
program and it is not that there is some
event that actually causes you to
transition but
you need to know when it is that you are
you know when it is the time to put away
childish things when it is that you are
responsible at the level of an adult
when it is that you are allowed to avail
yourself of the extra tools that come
with adulthood
and the point is we blurred all of these
distinctions
imagining them antiquated or something
and
of course that's insane it's you know
yet another example of uh
chesterton's everything right yeah it's
you know
who would have thunk that in a world in
which every culture had its rights of
passage that eliminating rites of
passage would have caused a problem
right right right you could see it
coming a mile away
um but we've done it and it's resulted
in
a
a permanent infantilization where people
never mature and
so at some level my feeling is
you know
is college necessary for everybody
is it absolutely required that we keep
our best people out of college so they
don't get their thinking polluted by
this insane mechanism in which they are
now being told that men can become women
two plus two might not equal four
um you know this is
the point is do we want them
i i'm going to avoid using the term that
is causing so much trouble in the last
two weeks but do we want them inculcated
into sophistry the people that we're
going to depend on to build the future
no we have to keep it away from them and
that's not to say that college couldn't
serve a purpose but it is to say that
modern college can't modern college has
proven that it can't and it has proven
that it can't because they've all failed
the same way if it could succeed then
some of them would be succeeding even if
it was a tiny fraction and the fact that
it's none tells us that mechanism is
lost indeed
so i was considering
actual coming-of-age rituals
uh like rome springer
of the amish
which is
for those who never heard of it
it's it's called the running around
period
um when amish youth of both sexes at 16
or 17
are
allowed
to be freed for some amount of time from
the restrictions
and many of the perks of the amish
community and church and then at the end
of some period they must they must
choose they must choose to either
come back into the fold
with all of the
positives and negatives that accompany
that or to reject um
their
life here too far
up until then uh completely and to go
out into the world and not be amish so
am i am i correct that um you said it a
little a little too carefully i think
okay they are allowed to participate as
a modern person well i yeah i said it
very carefully because though i didn't
spend a lot of time and mostly the books
i'm
i don't have access to a good library
anymore one of one of the few perks of
modern college affiliation is an
excellent library so um there
i
i dug as much as i could in the little
bit of time that i spent at it and it
seems
that the for those who have heard of it
mostly what we have in our heads is kind
of a time of um you know almost like
spring break right it's like it's like
college kids on spring break all the
restrictions are off and they're gonna
be at their worst right i think um brum
springer often actually has some um
adult amish still in like still
overseeing there's still some ac there's
still a lot of organized activities um i
i suspect that there's some of that but
it does seem like it's actually a much
more
um staid and less sort of orgyastic
experience
i would never have imagined that a
person raised amish liberated to do what
they want would go spring break i mean
you know i think frankly most kids avoid
that well it's possible that there was
just a uh reality tv show uh about this
that got into people's heads because
that seems to be the thing that is in
people's heads about it well my guess
would be
if you've been properly raised and if
there's one thing that an amish
community is likely to do it's to
properly raise its children yeah um then
you liberate them and they're going to
be
skeptical of an awful lot of what the
modern world has to offer i wouldn't
admit but also quite curious sure yeah
of course of course but anyway the basic
point is they are liberated to some
extent maybe fully what that means they
actually do is an open question and then
i think it's a year they it varies it
varies they come back and they have to
decide whether they want to continue
effectively in the modern world where
they want to return to their yeah so i
guess that that version is much tidier
than the actual
reality is part of why i was being very
careful because i had i had a couple of
things in my head sort of that that
version and then the like the spring
break version and neither of them are
true it seems yeah um
but
you know probably to some degree there's
as much variation as there are people
who engage in this uh one thing that i
think holds from what we have understood
in the past is that um the vast majority
like you know almost to a person
come back into the fold come back
to to be amish again but anyway that got
me thinking about uh this video that i
saw back in october of 2021
uh in which a
uh
well actually why don't we just why
don't we zach if you would play the
first uh almost two and a half minutes
of this
it's a it's a news report on a channel
that hopefully will be obvious
when it comes to actions taken to
address the covet 19 threat hindsight is
still very much underway
for your consideration a story and
outcome you probably aren't hearing much
about anywhere else it takes place in
the heart of amish country
lancaster county pennsylvania thousands
of families lead lives largely separate
from modern america
the amish are a christian group that
emphasizes the virtuous over the
superficial they don't usually drive use
electricity or have tvs
and during the covet 19 outbreak they
became subjects in a massive social and
medical experiment
so it's safe to say there was a whole
different approach here in this
community when coronavirus broke out
and many other places absolutely
calvin lapp is amish mennonite there's
three things the amish don't like
and that's government they won't get
involved in government they don't like
the public education system they won't
send their children to education and
they they also don't like the health
system
they they rip us off those are three
things that we
feel like we're fighting against all the
time well those three things are all
part of what covet is
after a short shutdown last year the
amish chose a unique path that led to
covid 19 tearing through at warp speed
it began with an important religious
holiday in may
when they take communion they they dump
their wine into a cup
and they take turns to drink out of that
cup so you go the whole way down the
line
and everybody drinks out of that cup
so if one person has a friend of ours
the rest of church is going to get
credit of ours first time they went back
to church
everybody got crewn of ours
lapp says they weren't denying
coronavirus they were facing it head on
it's the worst thing to
quit working than dying
but to shut down and say that we can't
go to church we can't get together with
family we can't see our old people in
the hospital we got to quit working
you're working it's going completely
against everything that we believe
and you you're changing our culture
completely to try to act like they
wanted us to act the last year
and we're not going to do it
so he says
there's three things that the amish
won't get involved with government
education and health care and those
three things are all central in the
coveted response
remarkable remarkable and there is a
so i don't know if you'll remember this
but when we first started discussing
writing
the hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
i wanted chapter one
to be
titled are the amish right
that of course got long since abandoned
as we developed our idea of what should
be in there but i i think the question
is an important one because the amish of
course
seem
strange to us it's like the very
definition of anachronism to be driving
your horse in you know 2022 on asphalt
on asphalt right um on the other hand
given the theme of the book which is
hyper novelty or at least that's one of
the central themes of the book is hyper
novelty the question is well all right
you have these people who
bailed out of technology or bailed out
of the advance of technology
and the question really is
at a net level
were they right that the trouble is not
worth it and
um in any case later in this in this
video um
he says
no the the narrator says the journalist
says
one thing's clear there is no evidence
of any more deaths among the amish than
in places that shut down tight some clay
that some claim there were fewer here
that's without masking staying at home
or much vaccination
right which raises all kinds of
interesting questions because the amish
are not in a great position to perfectly
protect themselves to the extent right
and as we as we hear here they get you
know they they believe and you know many
people have had this experience and you
know what why are we distrusting
mistrusting male trusting i don't even
know what the word is anymore um uh
people who say okay someone had coveted
and they did the sharing the
i we can't hear it when you watch it so
i don't remember if it was wine or what
if they're
they're sharing the thing and then
everyone got sick
right and then they ended up um all
better
and but what i mean is they can't
protect themselves from the folly of the
modern world in the sense that if yeah
vaccination drove the evolution of
variants they're exposed to variance too
so to the extent that what this story is
about is about herd immunity
they are not in a position to prevent
the thing from evolving away because of
what modern folks are doing to it rather
than what they did
nonetheless in spite of that
um
the
benefit of doing
it's not even exactly nothing but the
benefit of not imagining that you were
going to outwit technologically this
virus
may well have been superior in the
aggregate and this is one of the things
i really
i don't know that we will ever get an
honest accounting of it yeah but i think
it's very important that at some point
we get an honest accounting of the
difference between i think it would be
three categories one is what we did
right what were the consequences of that
for human health well-being and
longevity
there's a question and also things like
happiness uh
damage
um second thing would be
if one did nothing
right
and the third thing would be if someone
if we had approached it organically
rather than the top down
the cdc's gospel
view of what we should have done if
doctors were allowed to do what doctors
are supposed to do which is be
scientists and
try out things based on the symptoms
they see in front of them and discover
what works and compare notes and you
know prescribe as they will
and that actually um
i'm we're not spending as much time on
some things as i thought we might
because we spent so much time on vitamin
d i guess um
but that actually is a great segue to
another piece i read this week that i'm
gonna that i'm just gonna read a tiny
bit of here but um
but in it the author
argues and we've made this argument
we've seen lots of other people making
this argument for you know in your
organic category
not so much a category as a category in
your organic category um
you effectively left the space for
individual doctors to figure out what
worked
and
what you didn't say but i'm sure is
included in your organic category is
as opposed to having a blanket policy
and one treatment for everything all the
time everywhere saying okay you know
what
the infection fatality rate is so much
higher
the older you are
that
perhaps we should strongly encourage
um
more invasive treatments
the older you are and actually
discourage treatments that we know come
with costs the younger you are because
the younger you are the more likely you
are to get it not notice it then have
immunity
uh the idea of protecting yourself
against all costs and thus leaving your
immune system
um
potentially naive to it until a later
point at which point you will be more
susceptible is
batshit crazy medical policy is what it
is so this piece uh is was sent to us by
a fan this week i would not have run
into it otherwise and
my computer has decided that it's going
to take this moment to not pull it up
that's really what's that
it is it's spinning
okay
um so this is in an outlet called the
gray zone which i never heard of before
written by
an academic called christian parenti
published the last day of march of this
year title is how the organized left got
covered wrong learned to love lockdowns
and lost its mind and autopsy it's a
very long piece it's excellent
i'm just going to read the first two
paragraphs and this is written by
a left-leading academic as far as i can
tell i mean i think he says that in
there but you can also just kind of tell
that he is
he says it is hard to destroy your own
cause and feel righteous while doing so
yet the american left has done it after
more than two centuries at the vanguard
of the struggle for freedom the american
left broadly defined executed a volte
foss
i looked up how to pronounce this a
volte face i saw a lot of okay it means
an about face i don't know why we're
using that i'm gonna start over yeah
okay oh hello uh it is hard to destroy
your own cause and feel righteous while
doing so yet the american left has done
it after more than two centuries the
vanguard of the struggle for freedom the
american left broadly defined executed a
volte face and embraced
anti-working-class policies marketed as
purely technical public health measures
for two years the left has championed
policies of surveillance and exclusion
in the form of punitive vaccine mandates
invasive vaccine passports socially
destructive lockdowns and radically
unaccountable censorship by large media
and technology corporations for the
entire pandemic leftists and liberals
call them the lockdown left cheered on
unprecedented levels of repression aimed
primarily at the working class those who
could not afford private schools and
could not comfortably telecommute from
second homes
and he if i may thank you zach he then
he spends some time in that vein
and then says arguing reason against
covet hysteria is like attempting to put
out a magnesium fire using water but i
will try anyway
and he and then it's just
a reasonable argument after a reasonable
argument including this one about
actually
a blanket policy a vaccinate everyone
immediately never made sense given what
this disease looks like
and
i don't think
i don't often feel like we've been
trying to put out a magnesium fire with
water but that is to some degree um
what it has been on occasion we've also
been trying to figure out what
the narratives are that are being used
against people are
so that we can help pull people out of
their anxiety and their fear and their
propagandized mindsets and start to see
something that's real again but it is it
is tough and i feel like this piece
along with increasing numbers of others
reveal that there are a lot of people
who were saying for for god's sake can
can we can we please get this history
right
else we are certain
to repeat it because there are some who
would like us to
well there is an epic battle to prevent
us from doing the postmortem properly
right or if the postmortem is done
properly to demonize it in advance so
people won't be able to figure it out
and i must say i think a lot rests on
our ability
to override the force that would like us
not to do it yep um i will point out
that a an epic battle is coming
uh over the difference between
um
consequences in 2020 and 2021
because the point is anything that
happened as a result of our vaccine
policy
will be easily blamed on covid and the
difference between what happened in 2020
and 2021 is the place to see that
distinction
but
anyway very very interesting to hear
that that has emerged it sounds like
a very bold academic it will be
interesting to see what happens to him
yeah
so uh in in keeping with that
you want to say something about vaccine
mandates
yeah i did there's actually a rally
today in la which
i couldn't attend
but i wanted to make a certain point
that has dawned on me
over the course of months
there's obviously a relationship between
these mandates and um
tragedies of the past and anybody who
raises that connection is subject to
being demonized as somebody who is
uh taking you know the deaths of jews
and the holocaust lightly or something
like that and
frankly i'm having none of it right
we are in a place
where the lessons of the past are
directly relevant because we are
remaking mistakes that we've seen before
we remaking them identically no are we
remaking them for the same reasons
probably not but are those lessons
relevant and if so are we liberated to
talk about them we damn well better be
and the point i wanted to make
is
we are watching the rollback of
the nuremberg code and the gains made at
nuremberg and i believe we're seeing it
on two separate fronts that are easily
conflated because it went down in such a
way that they were both in play
one of them has to do
with the idea that a human being is
morally obligated to reject immoral
orders
this is a very important principle the
nazis were put on trial at nuremberg all
used the defense that they had been
following orders
and the point was the world correctly
decided that no such defense was viable
that if the order was immoral you had an
obligation to reject it even though
that's obviously a very
uh dire choice right and you know
let's give the defense it's due
does that mean you know in states that
have the death penalty that if somebody
tells you you know that you are
obligated to put somebody to death that
you are obligated to reject it it's not
clear what it means because it's not
clear that it's an immoral order now i
happen to personally oppose the death
penalty i believe they're cases in which
it is morally justified but that we
actually don't have a system good enough
to deploy it and therefore we don't need
it it isn't useful and we should forbid
it we will be more civilized if we
forego it but it doesn't mean there
aren't people who've earned it right
right you like i prefer to make the
other error
i think we have to make the other error
it's the civilized error to make but in
any case the point is there are lawful
orders potentially or at least arguably
that do result in a person you know
going to war there are wars that are
justified and you will kill other people
during them so is it an immoral order
just because somebody dies no not
inherently
but the nazis claim to have been
following orders
was
ruled
a non-defense
right right
now we are in the process of um
purging our police forces our military
our universities our hospitals of
exactly the people who were most likely
to raise objections people who recognize
that there was something wrong with
these mandate policies and refused to
either apply them to others or to accept
them for themselves the number of people
we've heard from
who have nurses in the family or doctors
but we've heard from more nurses and
nurses in the family who are no longer
allowed to work
in an era when we are also being told
that we that
not so much now but two months ago you
know the hospitals are overfill or
overflowing right
we're in crisis mode and yet we're
firing people for making a choice of
conscience right and what i would say is
whether it's intentional or not the
consequence that this policy of firing
people from police forces the military
hospitals universities for resisting is
to create
police forces military
universities hospitals in which people
are much less likely to object to
immoral orders and that is hugely
dangerous you leave behind a compliant
population right but the other way in
which we were rolling back nuremberg is
that nuremberg focused on the medical
experiments that were inflicted on
victims and concentration camps
now
what was ruled at nuremberg was that
human beings have a right to informed
consent that is to say that they have to
be able to say no to participating in
experiment and they have to have the
basis on which to make the judgment
themselves which means they need to be
fully informed
now
we have pointed out before
that these vaccines mrna vaccines for
example
are
one of the probably the largest medical
experiment in human history but for one
thing but for the fact that we are
apparently not systematically collecting
data on what happened to people who got
them and comparing it to people who
didn't in order to figure out how
dangerous or not they are so it is an
experiment in one sense in the sense
that we don't know but it is not an
experiment in the sense that we are not
taking even that responsibility
seriously
yeah it's an experiment in the
lay person
in the lay sense of experiment but it's
not a scientific experiment right and if
there's one thing we can be certain of
you and i having traversed this ground
many times it's that it is almost
impossible to find good information on
what the risks are
and how common the harms are and when
you do look at what evidence we do have
you're told it's not reliable without
being told what is reliable and so the
point is the informed consent
requirement that was established so
thoroughly i mean we literally hung
doctors
right we hung doctors as a result of
those trials right
that informed consent is now out the
window we are in an experimental phase
there are things that are true
based on whether or not the vial that
you happen to be injected from is part
of the emergency youth use authorized
batch or whether it is the
fda approved version and apparently the
authorized batch is the only thing you
can get in the u.s this is a baroque
landscape that no person could possibly
understand where their interests
actually are and what risks they're
being put to so informed consent is out
the window and those who would object on
the basis that they are being asked to
in to apply an experimental remedy to
people who have not been informed
properly those people are subject to
losing their jobs and so
i don't know if the if the um
rolling back of the gains of nuremberg
is intentional but i do know that it's
extremely dangerous and what i would say
is that we are effectively setting the
stage for
a tragedy of history
uh and
we are obligated
to recognize that and to resist with
everything we've got wow excellent
excellent uh you actually reminded me of
yet something else
that i saw this week that um might
actually be worth sharing here
um
which i haven't shared with you before
but it is in keeping kind of with what
you've been saying here
the oregon health authority whose emails
i receive
asked for people who are vaccinated but
not boosted to fill out a questionnaire
i did not because i do not qualify
but i did go and see what the options
were it's a one question questionnaire
and it reads oregon health authority
vaccinated but not boosted help us
understand about 75 of people age 18 and
older across oregon have completed their
first series of vaccinations and only 45
have also received a booster dose we're
hoping to understand some of the reasons
why people have thus far not received a
booster if you've been fully vaccinated
but have not had a booster shot please
select the one reason that most closely
represents your situation all responses
will remain anonymous situation they
said that about an anemone several times
on the page and there was no
obvious way for them to have collected
any information about you
uh so it was a it was
strange and suggested something about
them being able to collect something
from the computer you were logging in to
i i just i'm not sure why they kept
saying that all responses remain
anonymous given that they never
collected anything any identifying
features of you
okay their options that they offer are i
am young and healthy and don't believe i
need it
i would like to get a booster shop but
just haven't gotten around to it
i would like to get a booster shot but i
haven't been able to make the time or
don't have easy access to provider or
clinic
i got co-ed anyway and don't believe the
vaccine works well enough
i had side effects from the vaccine and
don't want to go through that again
people around me are getting coveted 19
and they seem okay so why bother
i want to wait until there was a newer
vaccine that targets the ba.2 omicron
sub-variant
that's a lot of reasonable reasons in
that list
i'm this this list surprises me um
i think many people will not have just
one
one thing on here but this is a match
you know if if the oregon health
authority is concerned because 75
of oregonians are what they consider
fully vac well two dose or one dose of
jnj vaccinated but not boosted and only
45 percent
are boosted um that's a big gap um
that's a big loss
um in um for the messaging for the
success of the messaging
and i said sometime back in the fall
this hopefully is where the narrative
crumbles because if they mandate
boosters they're they're going to reveal
how many people will not get boosted
um what we were hearing were a lot of
these things we were hearing from people
i had an adverse event i'm not going
there again i did it it wasn't one and
done like i was told i'm not going there
again or yeah i still got covered what
the hell or actually where's the new one
right like where's the one from for
omicron that we were promised apparently
in march and that um no one is really
talking about anymore if it you know if
it was so quick
to to figure out how to make these in
the first place and it didn't actually
take from you know
march to november of 2020. it was it
actually took kind of a weekend and then
it took a lot of uh of
production and trials which were
faulty in their own way um but they're
just
this is a list that reflects
more of the reality of what is actually
going on on the ground with people who
are experiencing covet and vaccines than
anything else i have seen from any
public health messaging yeah i think you
know
somebody is trying to figure out
who to target with what message sure you
know you can get them to change their
mind of course it's not a pure they
don't have a pure goal
my point would be so it accidentally
reveals
the truth of this which is that over
time people woke up to many of the
concerns now there were things that
weren't on there that should have been
unless i misheard it right in other
words the evidence suggests that these
vaccines are more dangerous than they
were represented to be
um yeah that's not that's that's that's
a theoretical objection right whereas
the only thing they have on here is i
had side effects from vaccine i don't
want to go through that again right so i
mean well they do have i got covered in
any way and don't believe the vaccine
works well enough which was also a
conflation of inflation yeah they do
rescue their little study here with
other
yes yeah i didn't include there's no but
it has to be there because it's hardly a
complete solution set so you need a
garbage category somewhere to catch all
those other explanations but
um
but anyway i do think
it reveals that yes people were reached
by messages that were demonized but
nonetheless they heard them and people
had experiences with themselves or other
people having reactions and and that
resulted in uh
more awakened
more people awakened than they would
have hoped for yes
indeed
okay uh you ready to uh
to finish us off here yeah yeah yeah
that sounds dire
no i don't think we're there yet i mean
it's spring it's spring yeah we're gonna
get some months of uh some some relief
yeah the the question is
um in light of elon musk having taken a
major stake in twitter and joining the
board and in light of peter thiel's very
interesting talk at the bitcoin
conference in miami which i know you
haven't seen yet but
well worth listening to what he has to
say it's extremely challenging
interesting talk i didn't follow 100 of
it but i got most of it um he basically
levels an accusation at what he calls
the gerundocracy
um
basically he claims that uh
very powerful
uh
boomer um
or older even maybe
uh
financial forces are suppressing the
natural growth of bitcoin anyway it's a
very interesting talk he makes an
argument
for the difference between
bitcoin and ethereum he's not a full
believer in ethereum it's clear but
nonetheless he lays out a framework in
which they're actually playing different
roles
he said one thing i quite disagree with
which is that to say that your
pro-blockchain
um
is an anti-bitcoin stance i don't think
that's true uh but nonetheless it's it's
a it's a it's a challenging interesting
talk in which he very forcefully comes
out in favor of bitcoin says that it
predicted inflation that the markets
didn't catch
those are very interesting things and
mark andreessen
uh who is uh another major force a a
tech guy who was
the prime mover behind netscape mozilla
right in the early days of the web
he has started calling out what he calls
um the current thing right so he's now
just started replacing you know
covid ukraine whatever with the generic
the current thing and his point is oh
you know you're not allowed to reason
about the current thing you're allowed
to reason about the last thing and
anyway by calling it this he reveals the
absurdity of this sort of flocking
behavior that people have to these
positions that they don't understand
um anyway i would argue that all three
of these are suggestive
of gen x rising but there is a level at
which you know eric has been big on
pointing out how uh you know the age of
people who win nobel prizes has gone up
and up and up um you know the just the
degree of power that has concentrated in
these elderly folks we can see it in the
last presidential election you know the
two oldest people to have run
um that the gerontocracy is now
increasingly facing
a
group of very powerful gen xers who i
think are fed up who have had it and do
not like
the woke nonsense
and are
potentially
let us hope
going to
break the stranglehold on power and
narrative that they have held
hopefully in favor of something better
more nuanced and more careful
but i just wanted to call attention
uh call people's attention to the fact
that you sort of had three blips of
these people who have become very
wealthy and powerful who seem to be fed
up and are simultaneously on the move in
the same week right that that feels to
me like something is up
well let's keep our eye on it yeah
indeed
fantastic okay that's it i think so
that's it
we've put our cat to sleep but that's
easy
we have put our cat
our cat is sleeping yeah maybe it wasn't
us who did it
all right uh we are going to take a
15-minute break
and we'll be back
um with answers to the questions that
you post at www.darkforsubmissions.com
uh we will try to get through as many as
we can in an hour you can email
legitimate questions that you might have
call in me
excuse me um to darkhorsemoderate
gmail.com
again consider joining our patreons
find me at natural selections my sub
stack where you can subscribe for free
to get almost everything free to your
inbox
read our book
and without further ado
be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside
[Music]
foreign